[Music]
Yoji like I need to warn you about
something yeah chef Willie is coming
back like the French guy yeah the like
palma du fromage mm-hmm you know I'm a
diplomat
that dudes kind of like it's kind of
like Giga Ramsay like it's kind of like
borderline abusive I don't know I kind
of liked him he's kind of scary I mean
he was you were fine with him he was
about to make you his like sous-chef for
some she don't even know what that is
like I mean but irony's got like a rat
like in his hat really yeah like it
controls my life that's time that's why
it's such a good [ __ ] cook do you
come when he doesn't have his hat I
don't know where he puts that on but
he's like good it's fine don't worry
about it don't worry about it
like I said always believe in yourself
thank you
yeah Joey I mean yeah I'm rich Brian and
I'm Joe G last summer we became master
chefs at the ad a rising summer mansion
and this year we're teaming up with even
more chefs and special guests and asking
a few of our 80 a rising labelmates to
help us out welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion
[Music]
you'll end up Amrish Brian I'm Georgie
and we're back at feast mansion the
greatest [ __ ] cooking show in the
world almost professional Ramsay and
yeah and today what do we got here man
I was feeling kind of western today I
thought if there's like some sort of
party later than maybe like you know we
make some burgers all right all right
American style okay dude I think of I
think I have the perfect I think I have
the perfect man for that Chef Ludo yeah
yeah good woman
thank you having Miami back huh thank
you guys thank you good job the last
time oh yeah I had a great job
[Music]
how's your cooking no I'm in it oh it's
so much better and you it's a lot better
yeah been watching that video a lot man
good and watching like our own video as
a tutorial is it tutorial are you guys
I'm about to flip the omelet so let's
hope I don't [ __ ] this up no I don't
drink any fun sitting Bull when you like
[Music]
bad today we're going to do a big neck
yeah I know I am big big big big big
yeah it was a big max a Big Mac Big Mac
yeah it's already it's already happening
yeah whatever
okay talk about the burger guy suppose
the be McBeal girl you know it was very
important for me to do like a very a
burger at the restaurant but it's a
burger I need to be French okay how you
make a burger French by making amazing
sauce and I do this Bob do that sauce
with your base of red wine okay and veal
stock it's a burger - it almost with a
fork and knife you see I'll show you why
what I do with my meat I use hanger
steak hanger steak okay shop ribs short
on everything you mix it and what that's
for okay and I put two body in my burger
each party is for ants shut up cheese
okay
boyish bone no way brioche yeah you know
why why because they taste really good
yeah French so first we're going to
toast the bomb so you put some chili
butter here okay
make sure the beer soaked so the fun see
Marty just that some toast all right so
now we take our putty so you have a mix
of kosher salt and black pepper so make
sure this is in your book side okay
unload the sword here you one via black
pepper
what up all right
[Music]
moving it with my with your mind I love
to put to party yeah but some people put
the big thing of body hung like a
quarter pound exactly then have to fill
very thin body and will you smack them
you know that's I agree I'm gonna - I'm
a - patty you know as well
Seren put that servin with into meds if
she's a third beat alright put into a
veneer okay
how many how many Fahrenheit so Thousand
Island yeah so [ __ ] you know generous
and share what you want a lotta so now
I'm gonna go over there this is really
getting outta know we could've are gonna
sue okay so that's the build you a very
French boat the red sauce red wine and
beef stock shallot and I will put it up
here I can see how are you Chris so
where's the rat that you hide in the is
you don't have a chef's hat so we're not
no where's the rat was that right the
rat that controls you cuz it's like
you're like ah so right like attitudes
in movies yes but where's yeah the I
don't have a rat so yeah there's just
never have a rat in my life you're just
that good
I'm gonna not go right in the kitchen my
god
I won't drag a squeezy two kids okay
yeah when you like this would you do
that yeah it's Brian's way this is
looking for affirmation like this is the
bread is toasted very nicely how do you
say okay bowl so see this very simple I
don't mean he's one of us there's a
bread and the pony and the sauce that's
it
and trust me this we need to have a
[ __ ] knife and we Wow
crackhead and would eat the sauce with
that thanks steak with bread so that's
what is French you know attack good
acting lots of sauce in Segovia
[Music]
Chef Ludo thank you so much for showing
us the French twist up a burger that was
literally the best burger I've ever had
so I want to try making like an
Indonesian burger that I would uh I'm
gonna I'm gonna make my own Indonesian
burger it's like the satay burger
Joey what do you make us I would love to
make for you a teriyaki burger
replicated by McDonald's my man Ronald
is like he's a clown but he's cool yeah
yeah so you know last year at me and Joe
to work together they're kind of you
know impress you but I feel like this
year we're gonna go kind of head-to-head
on this burger making competition and
you know whoever wins gets to be your
sous chef let's do this dinner yeah yeah
amazing you know
[Music]
this is the teriyaki right okay yeah now
I remember how some of these shits were
made so you're using this book are you
Jody Nugent pop this is pork it looks
the same but oh but that's fine that's
no worry about it
oh [ __ ]
what's up I burnt it Oh Oh
abomination oh okay
you good y'all are out here trying to
make me
Oh watch this that's hot oh you put them
a like that ah maybe maybe right oh yeah
what are using what's the okay so this
dose yeah
satay sauce usually includes some peanut
sauce and sweet soy sauce in it and yeah
yeah we tether peanuts it but yeah yeah
was it bread is still very wet okay he's
so good he to give a nice correlation
this burger you know what if my music
ends up sucking then I'm gonna work at
McDonald's hey no kidding
they won't hire me not for an
altercation in 2008 okay okay
[ __ ] time to bid zip bill get out
what is these but this is this is a
little bit humble
ah just a little bit just a little vibe
for some dry scream like that yeah am I
am I just to give a little crunch yeah I
get a little crunch I put on some
cucumber just to get that little crunch
in there cuz you know Jody has the
crispy transition frame yeah I'm Thomas
- yeah I got that
I felt fine I've had a egg in this
before
[Music]
ah ah chopsticks
nice okay I smell so this is a this is
my Indonesian burger right there this is
my custom UT teriyaki burger I caught
the the fur burger it's so good I call
it the fur burger because it's like it's
special special type of burger burger
burger yeah
[Music]
I except me and Jody you worked really
hard on our burgers and [ __ ] so me and
Jed you work really on his burgers and
then you know it taste it I'm excited
I'm gonna I'm gonna cut my you know
[Music]
okay okay okay no no no this is the
lives of V know what it's okay I'll
reassemble it once uh once so first I'm
going to try your Brian girl girl okay
look good easy to take thank you yeah
[Music]
wait let me let me just yeah okay I wash
my hands don't wanna know okay so now
able to try to build a goatee huh
yeah it's over I'm gonna just I'm just
pack it pack it it's done
[Music]
all right so Ludo you try both of our
burgers yeah so what do you think
Brandon will you love your girl girl I
think was built very well thank you meet
a lot of good over over there I'm very
easy to eat and love with the statuses
will you love it and the crunchiness of
the cucumber and the beef was great
well language well executive Thank You
Georgie what a me yeah girl love your
technique thank you
it was so food to what you believe the
bloggers love you approach about the
portions of teriyaki mean gloves of eggs
I mean everything making sense you just
missing something or little chicken your
burger you know it's the teriyaki burger
I don't test that versatility
can we all hold him so it's like the the
boxing thing so it was a very diverse
aluminous decision
in my head you know and the winner is
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you thank you thank you so
much for teaching us thank god you're
just missing more territory schools
broke I know I thought that's it you
know what it was let's see no you know
what it was yesterday we had a pizza
episode and the dude was like don't use
too much marinara sauce are you gonna
[ __ ] it up and then I had that in my
head and I was like oh I can't use too
much teriyaki that's it's totally
different countries I don't why there we
go
next time more teriyaki all right so you
know me and GOG we just obviously made
the best burgers in the world and you
know but I won I'm sorry Jody but so I'm
gonna start my job tomorrow with Ludo at
7:00 a.m. as your sous chef yes and yeah
and I'll go back to my stem collection
and we're feets mansion the greatest
[ __ ] cooking show in the world
Chef Ludo thank you so much for coming
back to us and yeah don't you guys but
cheers again cheese so much cheese
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update our first ever
collaborative sauce it's here
88 rising first we feast joining forces
to make dragon in the clouds
you saw me Joe G and rich Brian mixing
it up in the cauldron yuzu from Japan
etc I'm peppercorn from China and of
course you know your boy brought the
heat but don't worry we got some
professionals together to make sure this
stuff is FDA approved extremely limited
very quality and something what we're
super proud of if you want to get your
hands on dragon in the clouds visit 88
night market calm that's 88 night market
calm don't miss your chance the dragon
you can fly away
[Music]
you
[Music]